hello there today we'll look at sparse
is enough in scaling transformers by
researchers of the university of warsaw
google research and open ai this paper
on a high level proposes a set of
building blocks to introduce sparsity
into transformers and this results in an
architecture called the scaling
transformer in the second half of the
paper they then introduce additional
features to the scaling transformer
to make it into the terra former both
the scaling transformer and the
terraformer they're really fast at what
they call unbatched decoding decoding is
essentially inference in such a
transformer model and unbatched means
that they can do this for a single
sample of course they're also faster in
batch decoding but i guess the effects
are not as pronounced and we're going to
see why because the sparsity really
shines through if you have single
examples and can only activate very
small parts of the network at the same
time
so the effect of all of this
at least for the scaling transformer is
right here if you have a model with 800
million parameters i guess today that be
called a small model
uh the baseline transformer has a
decoding time of about 0.16 seconds
whereas if you add all the tricks to the
scaling transformer you speed that up by
a factor of about 2.6 x that's not that
pronounced yet yet the effect really
shines if you go to bigger models so if
you go to a 17 billion parameter models
the baseline transformer takes about 3.6
seconds
on this particular hardware to decode
the tera no sorry the scaling
transformer with all the tricks
activated takes about 0.18 seconds
giving a speed up of 20x and uh so in
different settings on different
configurations these speedups can in
fact get even higher i've seen up to
like
37x or something like this which is
quite quite fast and this all
while the performance doesn't degrade
and that is um
surprising
so they say surprisingly the sparse
layers are enough to obtain the same
perplexity as the standard transformer
with the same number of parameters so
they have the same number of parameters
it it's just that they activate them
sparsely when forward propagating which
is much faster and needs much less
memory
and this results in the same perplexity
when language modeling so essentially
means that the performance is on par
and also they say
if they
if they integrate with prior sparsity
approaches that's where they achieve the
terraformer uh
they can do fast inference on long
sequence even with limited memory this
results in performance competitive to
the state of the art on long text
summarization which is another thing
where their model is
state of the art or equivalent to state
of the art
while being much more sparse much more
memory efficient and much faster
so yeah we'll dive into this the
architecture it's quite it's quite a
mess like there are engineering tricks
engineering tricks engineering tricks um
and you know the the
you have to wonder a little bit you know
what came first like which trick came
first and which trick necessitated which
other trick but we'll go through the
architecture uh through all the
different pieces and you'll see what
this is all about and where the savings
are done
all right if you enjoy content like this
you know don't hesitate to subscribe i
don't want to do the other youtubers
show the graph i'll i'll do like i'll do
this here's the graph here's the graph
ah so many of you are not subscribed i
mean look at that
excellent all right so
the point with the these sparsity gains
is that um
if you
implement them somewhere then that part
is fine but then another part is still
dense and is still the bottleneck so you
kind of have to introduce them
everywhere so if we look at a classic
transformer model and they specifically
i think refer to like the stack of
uh attention is all you need and so on
so what they have basically is they have
two
attention modules so there's attention
one
i think there's attention two and then
there is this feed forward layer okay so
we're going to take care of all of those
right here attention one is called
self-tension so if i have a sequence
coming in here
the self-attention would be essentially
a tension in between the elements of the
sequence
the second attention block is i think
encoder decoder attention or something
like this the variants vary a little bit
right here but i would have sort of a
second stack of this right here i would
have a input sequence right here so this
would be the input this would be the
target sequence that i'm about to decode
um maybe this has some causal attention
who knows
the second layer of attention here is
specifically attention that goes to the
uh encoder sequence right here
so it's it's
a tension in between the encoder and the
decoder and the feed forward uh
so this essentially these two mix all
the information of the different tokens
together and the feed forward layer
simply takes a single embedding of a
single single token and feeds it through
a feed-forward function so all the
tokens are handled by the same
feed-forward function
the first thing this paper does is it
essentially eliminates the
distinguishing between
the self attention and the attention
between
encoder and decoder and i think that
makes sense that's also a lot of what a
lot of other
models do so famously bert is an encoder
only model gpt is a decoder only model
and if i understand them correctly there
as well they're simply taking the
encodings from the
source and then just prepending them to
the target or
something like this you know safe to say
there are lots of things that one could
do right here
but
what i wanted to say is that we now need
to replace each of those things with a
sparse version so we need a sparse feet
forward
and we also need a sparse attention
block
so how we're going to achieve this first
we're going to the sparse feed forward
layer remember a feed forward layer is i
have a sequence
of embeddings so that's these are all
vectors and these are all embedding
vectors this is a sequence of embedding
vectors that came out of the attention
module right
and the feed forward layer essentially
is a matrix
um
and
i simply pass each of these through a
matrix in fact it's not one matrix i
think it is usually two matrices
one matrix that
sort of
well that's not how you draw a matrix
um
like this
and then like this
okay so you kind of blow up the
dimension in the middle and then here
there is a relu non-linearity in between
and the point is what i already said
you'd feed every single
token by itself through this function so
this becomes like a large token then
there's a relu and then this would
become sort of
a token of the input dimension again and
you feed this token through as well
individually which give you
this one and so on
so
in essence we have a vector right a a
token all the tokens are independent we
have a token and somehow we need to make
this sparse
right now it's a dense multiplication
twice so there's two matrices right here
and if dense multiplication right so
what do we do
the first thing they say is that well
given that there's a relu non-linearity
right here right there's a relu
a lot of the things here essentially are
going to end up being zero right so it
makes sense it makes sense to
do sparsity here now i don't i don't
follow that entirely um you know i guess
half of the stuff will end up being zero
yet
the sparsity goes much further so
but maybe maybe they
maybe they justify why they can set some
things to zero not entirely sure but i
found that reasoning a bit shaky but
here is essentially you know you don't
need any reason to introduce sparsity if
it works it's good
so here's how it works
first and this is what i found a bit um
confusing so it essentially starts on
the right then it goes to the left but
it i guess it's easier to start on the
left so what we want to do
we see here is that input vector right
and here is that first matrix so the
first matrix is of dimension
d model which is the same as this
dimension and dff which is the feed
forward
dimension
and usually i just multiply that
together which would give me a
vector in the dimension of the feed
forward layer right which i then send
through my relu
however however
what i want to do
i want to compartmentalize
i want only
certain
columns here to be activated
right so essentially say i already
accept that a lot of my things in my
result are going to be zero because you
know they will go to a relu anyway so
i'm gonna accept that some of the things
will already be zero so let's say all of
these i already accept they're gonna be
zero i don't even need to calculate the
matrix multiplication between the vector
here and let's say uh this column right
here don't need to do it because
after that they will become zero anyway
so who cares um so i'm simply going to
decide that some of the things are just
going to end up being zero and they
justify this by saying well there's a
relu so some of the things are going to
be zero but more more here's like you
know six out of eight are going to be
zero
and now i only need to calculate the
remaining columns and that is the
sparsity right here
um
effectively they subdivide all of the
they subdivide the whole matrix into
these compartments so we'd have two
different compartments right here
and of in each compartment only one
column can be activated at the same time
right i think yeah
yeah there's one one of them it's
decided on one of them one of them can
be activated and only that one needs to
be loaded from memory only that one
needs to be calculated uh
as an inner product with the vector
and so the cells here where an actual
value is going to be
are sparse now the question is how do we
decide which ones we're going to
activate by the way
if you can see then for the second
matrix you know the same thing applies
in fact i can use that same mask from
here and i can again say well
in the first module
column number three was activated here
right so row number three of this matrix
needs to be activated the other ones
don't matter because they're zero anyway
so there's a zero coming in right here
being multiplied with this row you know
who cares what the result is the the
input is zero actually well people care
it's zero right but it means you don't
even need to need to do it um you can
simply
just load the rows that you are that you
know are potentially non-zero
so yeah how do how do you decide how do
you decide which ones uh you should load
from memory
essentially you're simulating you're
already pre-committing to a relu pattern
right
so this is how you do it
essentially you build
you build
you
take your input vector right here
and you're trying to somehow we're going
to see how that works we somehow come up
with
a
vector
of
with a binary vector with numbers
between like 0 and 1. so everything
right here is like a point one point
five
point three
point
eight
so every single entry has a value every
single entry will output like the
probability that that particular element
should be non-zero and then you simply
sample from that distribution and use a
straight through gumball soft max in
order to back propagate
so
they also do a lot of tricks right here
i think they mentioned that
in the forward propagation they even
sometimes need to do
a actually to pass just the softmax
output instead of the actual sampling so
there's a lot of engineering tricks to
actually get this to work but safe to
say
that's during training we are we care
about inference during inference you
sample
exactly one per module that is non-zero
okay so you have two different
workflows
the workflow one
goes here decides what needs to be
non-zero right and then
given that information you can do this
feed forward layer in a sparse way but
that is all useless if this right here
is um
is not sparse so this is actually not
sparse but it is low rank so they say
well in order to figure out which things
need to be non-zero we technically don't
need as much information as you know
actually propagating information
so what we can do is we can have a low
rank
essentially it's another feed forward
layer
again
doing this blowing up the dimension to
the feet forward dimension
but we make it low rank so instead of
instead of
wait
yeah instead of blowing up the dimension
in between we shrink it down right you
can see right here we shrink it down to
a low dimension
and then we go to the dimension of the
feet forward layer
to decide which things are one and zero
and that's a thing you're going to see
often in this model is that they make
use of low rank
combined with sparsity
and it's also a bit of a
of a trouble
that i have because for some things a
low rank approximation is fine but you
know there's a reason we have dense
multiplications everywhere because
sometimes it's not because with a low
rank
multiplication you essentially restrict
your
function space to a very very small
subspace
yeah but it seems to work
so the trade-off here is that you get to
do this sparse which means that the time
it takes decreases and the memory but
you have to this here
over this this is new right you didn't
have to do this before you could simply
do the multiplication so this is going
to add to your compute well this here is
going to be faster
and now it's about whether whether or
not
you can make this side sufficiently low
rank
such that the the gains over here uh are
more than the time that you have to
invest to compute this max this mask at
the first place over here
again for these particular problems that
they look at it seems to be working
right but
these kinds of trade-offs it's not
guaranteed like it's not
so clear to me that it would you know
just work
um
like it's not it's not straightforward
that that trade-off would be positive
right here
there might very well be problems where
this rank right here is just too small
to carry meaningful information
you need to make it bigger and that
would sort of vanish
all the savings you make over here
because these savings are i mean
essentially
linear in the sparsity
and this these gain sorry these these
this right here is essentially linear in
the in the low rank dimension
so there's the trade-off right there
so they here is how you how you can
express this you can essentially express
this as the original multiplication with
the first matrix um
relu
through the relu then
times the controller output
and all of that then goes into the
second multiplication that's how you can
represent it mathematically that's not
actually what you do right because here
you still have the full multiplications
with the weight matrices
but it will result in the same thing as
this formula
all right
so that is the sparse feed forward layer
and they do show that it decreases
the coding time quite a bit and
interestingly it also doesn't degrade uh
performance too much in fact you can see
right here this blue line is the average
of the baseline models and if you if you
don't go too sparse um you still have
quite good performance so this is quite
close only if you go
more sparse uh does your perplexity here
start to suffer i think that that is one
of the surprising things that there is a
level of sparsity you can go at where
you're actually considerably faster
while your performance doesn't degrade
yet again can very well be because for
the problems we look at
the sort of the
they're not difficult enough to really
make use
of the capacities of the dense models
okay
so feed forward is done now we go to the
attention layer and the attention layer
again is split up into two parts in fact
they don't even they don't even really
deal with the attention mechanism itself
what they actually care about
is
in order to do attention attention is
something like
i have my queries and my keys and i do
an outer product and i normalize by
something that i can't remember
and then i multiply by my values
this is the attention formula and what
they care about is how do i get the
queries the keys and the values they
in order to make attention itself sparse
or or long-range or efficient they rely
on on different uh techniques that from
other papers so for example they will
later include the performer and the
reformer architectures
which make attention itself
sparse or efficient or low dimensional
however
in this particular paper they care about
how do we even get these matrices and
usually you get q
by multiplying your input
by
a weight matrix like wq you get
key by multiplying your input by a key
weight matrix and you get v by x so all
of these are dense multiplications
and obviously they now become the
bottleneck once we have the sparse feed
forward layers the dense layers
in
in the attention
layers become the bottleneck
the question is can we use the same
trick here as we did before and the
answer they say is no because the
structure of the feed forward layer here
was such that it had the relu in between
right so
and that's why they argue so naturally a
lot of things are going to end up being
0 which we can exploit by making you
know just just a few more things zero
i guess
but they don't they don't want to do
this right here because here like none
of the things
necessarily are going to be zero
in the output of these calculations so
the q or the k or the v
they don't have many zero entries so
might not be justified to
go sparse and just say well make stuff
zero
so
what do we do instead instead
we look at this diagram here
so on the top you have what
the current attention mechanism looks
like as i said there is a there is a
dense
uh layer essentially in front of each of
these three matrices which is that's how
you that's exactly how you get the
matrix in the first place all right
we're going to look at a
thing
which they call a multiplicative layer
so which this is this malt right here
and the multiplicative layer
potentially could replace the dense
layer however they go a step further and
they say
they end up with this architecture right
here where they have a multiplicative
layer
then
it's a one multiplicative layer for all
three matrices that is shared and then
one convolutional layer for each of the
different matrices which is going to
make stuff even faster and then they
also they drop kind of this uh this
dense mechanism right here and they
simply add right here
again i like
i'm pretty sure this works right now for
these particular problems
hope like maybe because the problems
don't make use of
of the parameters or
the original models were just
poorly engineered they didn't they never
actually needed all of these you know
parameters like this one and we're all
fine this could also be the case
so we have two things to look at inside
of the attention model the
multiplicative layer and the conv layers
and these kind of go together
and it also goes together with what's
usually done in the attention mechanism
which is multi-head attention
so i'll
draw a diagram of an attention mechanism
for the about 500th time but you have
some sort of a sequence right
and every sequence
i'll replicate the sequence over here so
every sequence emits what's called a
like a query which is a vector
some vector which are the queries and
also every element in the sequence emits
a key so the keys are also some vectors
and
the keys are also some vectors and
then routing is done via inner product
overlap so probably these go would be
routed together
these two would be routed together
this would probably be routed here
it can also be routed to multiple stuff
but you route essentially via inner
product
so that's how you construct the weight
matrix or the
query key matrix for then multiplying by
the values
the idea behind multi-headed attention
which is what's usually on is that let's
not only have one such block let's
actually have many such blocks in
parallel right and instead of using the
entire vectors that are output right
here by for example that are in queue q
are these the queries right q or is a
matrix and every row or column don't
exactly remember is one of these vectors
right here they say hey let's instead of
so q is
a matrix let's say every row but for for
let's just say every row if i'm wrong
then you know just reimagine
um
so instead of taking the entire
vectors here like the entire vectors as
queries we split the vectors into in
this case into three parts and this
first part right here that becomes the
query for this attention mechanism the
second part becomes the query for that
detention mechanism and the third one
becomes the query for yet another
attention mechanism that's multi-headed
attention same with the keys same with
the values
and
yeah so now
now we're prepared
so what we want to do
right here is
we want to
um
take
a token and remember we now need to make
a
query
let's say we want to produce the queries
right
so from this token we need to produce a
query vector
um
not only one but number of heads many
query vectors from this token using some
sort of
some sort of a linear layer
some sort of a linear function so that's
how we do it they say we have this
matrix right here the weight matrix d
and what the weight matrix d the weight
matrix d is
it has the same dimension here
as the input and has as many as many
rows as we have different attention
heads right
so
what we're going to do is we're going to
element wise multiply
and i would also add right here
broadcast right
broadcast so if you've used numpy or or
tensorflow or pytorch you know the
broadcasting operation so the
broadcasting is done this is of
dimension one right here the
broadcasting is done between this one
and this s right here
this is going to be broadcast
into this form right here and you can
see
now
i mean
it's just an element-wise multiplication
so all that is is like differently
scaled versions of x in each dimension
right so each row is essentially x
a little bit
shaky so let's double shake x for the
bottom row okay
but this already is now a vector
one vector for each of the attention
heads
um
now
since
element wise multiply is probably not
going to get us very far
we also
multiply this by an actual matrix but
instead of multiplying it by a d model
times the model matrix again we go into
a low rank
low rank regime and simply say okay we
have this number m and that's going to
be a reduction on
reduction on our
dimensionality so this isn't d modeled
by a d model matrix which would probably
be expensive it's a d model by m matrix
and out comes this so this is going to
be the query vector for the first
attention mechanism
sorry no
this is going to be the query vector for
the first attention mechanism
and
this is going to be the query vector for
the second attention head
head i meant to say head
there is a thing like they don't just
choose m arbitrarily they in fact choose
i believe
s times m equals
to
d model
right
that
is
that is their their formula so they
if they
split into s different heads like let's
in this case you see s is two then m is
3.
and that has a very particular reason
namely they say with this particular
construction of the element was multiply
followed by the
multiplication by this weight matrix e
if if we do it like this
then they can have a theorem where is
the theorem
there is the theorem
the theorem essentially says that they
can
um they can represent an arbitrary
permutation
so they say
the minimum thing the minimum thing that
we have to be able to do is to take x
and kind of permute it so
to place every single element of x
in the output wherever we want
essentially
they say
every part of x should be able to be
forward propagated to all the attention
heads or to any of the attention heads
and if a theorem that says that if they
construct it like this any permutation
is within
the um the realm is within possibilities
for some matrices for some weight
matrices d and e so that's kind of their
justification of well we can represent
all permutations so it can't be too bad
right
uh yeah i found a little bit of another
way
of you know seeing this if you look at
this with the element-wise multiple and
so on it is easier to understand this as
let me try to
draw this up maybe over oopsie boops
over here
so if you think about it a little bit it
is like so you have
and you also look at the formula this
formula right here
you can clearly see that this is in fact
a matrix multiplication again so you
have i would say you have if you look at
this as d
times
x times e
where x here is a matrix
that has
zeros but x on so on the diagonal it's x
right
which would give you
it would give you sort of a so d is
kind of this shape
then
x is
that shape but only the diagonal is
filled with x
and then e is like that shape
so
and d and e are fixed matrices
so you can see that uh what the mult
what this multiplicative layer is doing
essentially
is it
it defines outputs it defines outputs so
these are the number of outputs and this
is the dimensionality of the output
and what you're able to do is is in some
higher dimensional space you're able to
manipulate the coordinate system scaling
a little bit well a little bit
arbitrarily but you cannot mix the
individual dimension freely
you can simply in that high dimensional
space for a given mixing of dimensions
that's what these matrices here do for a
given mixing of dimensions for given
linear projections from the low
dimensional to the high dimensional
space
you're able to manipulate the coordinate
system
so if
if you learn you need to be able to find
matrices d and e such that for arbitrary
samples the manipulation of the
coordinate systems there makes sense
it's a little bit like
you know like doing a pca or something
on a
on a data set right but it's just like
during training right here
so
yeah i'm not sure
again this is quite this is quite a loss
this is quite a trade-off with an actual
dense layer right here
so
but it's interesting to see that it
works right and again this is only
conceptual right here um if you were to
actually do this you would lose all the
benefits that you would lose all the
benefits that you had and again you can
see a little bit that the trick here
isn't necessarily sparsity but mostly
low rank this is mostly like a low rank
um function
uh
yeah
okay so we have the multiplicative layer
we end up with the queries and the keys
and the values for each attention head
and
now we're going to
they essentially say okay we could do
this for every
one of the three things or or
we simply do it once
which would give us this
property of
would you give us this property of the
permutation being able
and
then we can do something even cheaper if
we want to get the individual matrices
right
and so the trade-off here as well here
still every permutation was possible for
the different matrices so
the queue could have different
permutations than k then v or different
functions here we're simply going to
resort to one function one mixing
or shuffling around of the dimension and
then we're going to do something even
cheaper which is this convolutional
module and this convolutional module is
also fairly
simple to see so this output y right
here and draw it again over here
you have two
vectors
right here
and they say it somewhere
they say the dimensionality somewhere
so you have two vectors one per
tension head this is the output of the
multiplicative layer
and
presumably
you would have those
per token right we just looked at one
token but the next token let me draw in
this color the next token would also
have them and then the next token would
also
have
uh two of those
all right let's do this
so what you'd get is
a tensor
that has the sequence length l
it has the number of heads what's s i
guess
or number of modules and it has
m which is that
that essentially that low rank
dimensionality
that the keys and queries and values
live in
and they simply treat this
as an image and then they run a
convolution across it
so the convolution is going to be let me
see if i can draw this properly the
convolution is going to be um across
these two so the filter is going to be
like this and then in all the dimensions
so
like this
i'm terrible at drawing but the filter
essentially is going to be
um f
in the dimension of s
f in the dimension of l
and m uh deep and you have m filters of
those so you
you have an
s by l by m tensor here and you
transform it also to an s by l by m
tensor
essentially you can just think of this
as a
regular convolutional layer
and what the again what does the
convolution go over
remember that the multiplicative layer
simply works on a single token
it uh
mixes
it kind of sh it is able to shuffle
around
the tokens dimensionalities a little bit
uh to permute them a little bit in the
best case and in all other cases it
essentially manipulates the scaling in a
high dimensional space
and now with the convolutional layer
what we can do is we can bridge a little
bit of information already between the
tokens even before we go into the
attention module
so given that the convolution is across
the l and the s dimension it means that
for the s dimension information is able
to be
passed between neighboring attention
heads and for the l dimension it means
information is being able to be passed
between neighboring tokens in the
sequence
so that potentially gives some sort of a
positionality to tokens because now that
there's a notion of being close together
and also it gives maybe a little bit of
a meaning to different attention heads
because the attention heads
up until this point they've just been
kind of unordered independent things and
now they
hang together a little bit
this all of this is
sort of one of the things why the the
the exact
um conclusions of this paper are going
to be hard to assess even if they do
ablations right they at the same time
where they introduce efficiency they
also introduce entirely new ways of of
sort of doing things they introduce new
paths when it where information can be
passed from between things and
so it's very hard to point down exactly
where things go right and wrong
so this was the sparse or
rather low dimensional
um attention module
again this is first one of these
multiplicative layers
which is element-wise multiply followed
by matrix multiplication to a lower
dimension
and
then that is followed by these um
by these convolutions by these
convolutional layers right here
so they call this whole thing a malt
conv
right if they combine all of this
together you can see right here
the blue with the shade is the average
of the bass lines this is perplexity so
lower is presumably better
and you can see up to some noise all of
these things are fairly consistent
right
they they follow the trajectory
of the baselines quite neatly uh some
are even kind of a bit lower this one
right here though i'm not sure if
there's a
there is exactly confusion because so
the f right here is the filter size
right and the s is the the sparsity
in the multiplicative layer so
essentially how many attention heads it
splits stuff into
and you can see right here there is a
conv
is just the conf and there's just the
mold but the f is with the malt which
confuses me because the f is the filter
size so technically that should be
with the conv i guess
um if
the authors are watching
please please leave a comment um if i'm
wrong right here other i'm confused
in any case
uh they show that
the
baseline transformer don't particularly
do that much
better in these nlp tasks or even do
worse sometimes as you can see right
here though everything is pretty much
within like a standard deviation
um than these scaling transformers so
this architecture that we've discussed
right now is this scaling transformer
the last thing to do would be to add a
sparse loss layer so they can replace
the
dense layer with a multiplicative layer
similar to previous sections this speeds
up the coding time say
sorry they say but
may degrade perplexity results are in
the appendix so the the lost layer might
not might be the last refuge of of
really dense uh things to do
but remember
due to the fact that
in the feed forward layers we sample
from this distribution uh to really be
sparse or in fact we might do argmax
right during inference um that's where
the speed up comes from during training
we actually have to forward propagate
the soft max from time to time so that
the training works and that means that
the benefits of sparsity are lost
because
if we don't hard sample ones and zeros
if we soft sample them then all the rows
are still activated and we need to track
everything and the same goes i think a
little bit for batch inference so if i
have batch inference even if i hard
sample right different samples are going
to have different
activation patterns and therefore you
know with enough samples all the things
are going to be one somewhere and
therefore i probably need to load the
entire matrix right here from memory i
need to do the multiplication with the
entire matrix possibly not for all the
vectors but
also possibly something like a gpu
probably wouldn't care that some stuff
is zero it's gonna be as fast just to do
all the things at the same
time but that might be a hardware
limitation
okay so
that was the scaling transformer and now
we're going to supercharge the scaling
transformer which makes it into a
terraformer i don't think there's any
relation to the tool terraform but
you know
we're running out of names of formers so
yeah
this was the last refuge i guess
so what they do is they use essentially
they use essentially the
architecture from the attention from
reformer so
yes
we focus on the l locality sensitive
hashing attention from reformer
was that reformer
i thought that was perform i am confused
by my
by my own stuff
reformer yes
so they do two things right they um have
an architecture for long sequences uh
while integrating sparse attention layer
into a scaling transformer we notice the
architecture is sub-optimal that's what
i said at the beginning
um separating decoder self-attention and
encoder decoder retention is not
necessary anymore from the perspective
of efficiency
we remove the encoder decoder attention
that i said that at the very beginning
but just concatenate the encoder
representation before the decoder tokens
so
they
replace the encoder decoder attention by
essentially two attention blocks
that is that okay
i guess there's no performer in here
just the reformer
so the lsh i've done a video on this
locality sensitive hashing
instead of full attention so if you have
really long sequences
you as i said you need to compute inner
products between all pairs between all
pairs of uh
of nodes right here of tokens
and this is cumbersome there are various
techniques to speed that up
one is lsh locality sensitive hashing
where you essentially create hash
buckets and then you hash all the
vectors also all the vectors inside of
it or all the
inner products
become hashes and you look for
essentially hash collisions that
indicate where you want to calculate and
check and a whole everything that's not
a hash collision you don't need to check
so locality sensitive hashing has been
long standing technique to
make inner product search in high
dimensions or inner product computations
and looking for the most close inner
product in in among very many elements
how very fast
so they borrow that from there
and then also they include the recurrent
blocks so recurrent blocks is
um
no
that's later first it's the
reversibility all of this is just so
similar
reversibility
is
also apparently in reformer
and what reversibility means it's kind
of this architecture right here so again
we have two attention and then one feet
forward right the second attention
replaces the encoder decoder attention
and reversible means that
instead of having one strand like one
flow of forward propagating information
right one flow of information we have
two so there's i1 and i2 input 1 and
input 2. we have 2 information flows
forward and then every function that's
applied is applied to one flow
and added to the other flow right this
gives you this and this one right here
is simply forward propagated as a
residual connection essentially
and
then x2 is taken so this the flow of the
actual function would be this right here
right you can see
this is the flow of
hitting all the functions
and
you can also see that we always have a
signal for each of the functions we
always have a signal that travels
without
being touched by the function right here
okay so
that signal right here and this is the
signal right here and that makes the
blocks reversible and that means that
um i can i don't have to keep
activations in mind
this limits
this limits the capabilities
a lot
so
non-rever an example for non-reversible
would be well this here is
non-reversible
because because unless i do like a
linear function that
goes from exactly the same dimension to
the same dimension that is
non-degenerate unless i do that
i cannot possibly reconstruct the input
right here like the the signal right
here x
from the output y not even for a single
one of those blocks right it's not
possible for me um essentially to do
this or
uh yeah so
the reversibility
changes that essentially means i can
always reconstruct from the from these
signals i can reconstruct the
intermediate activations and therefore i
don't need to store them because in a
normal neural network as i forward
propagate i need to store a lot of
intermediate stuff like right here and
right here in order to then during back
propagation i need those things um
because otherwise i couldn't calculate
the gradient so i need to store the
activation somewhere reversible networks
reversible
blocks do not have this property they do
not need to store because they're
reversible and they're made reversible
not by changing the individual modules
like this or this but by simply having
this construction of the two strands of
information and the modules simply apply
between the two
that's it's a pretty smart architecture
but one has to say it has
very often significant trade-offs
because
these things being reversible also bring
some some properties like there are a
lot of functions you cannot express
anymore because you need to keep
everything reversible
so again i think
for the problems they particularly look
at here it might work it might not work
for all problems i think that's a bit of
a
general thing in this um
this paper right here
it's more like we're gonna have to test
for every
new task we tackle or new challenges new
modalities whether these things still
hold
the last thing they build in is
recurrence and they say it's for
generalization
and that is if i understand it correctly
it is
they use uh simple recurrent units not
like an lstm because they say that would
be too slow so simple recurrent units
they're still fairly complicated like
i've looked them up they're i didn't
know what they were
they're still oh they're still okay
complicated so it's not just like a
recurrent layer it's actually you know
it has gates and so on like a bit like
gru's or
um
lstm cells
and if i understand correctly
this goes between so as i said before in
the feed forward layer that every single
token
goes independently through that
if i understand this correctly if i
understand this correctly
this introduces a recurrent
connection in between these
did i well did i understand it correctly
okay um
we also add a recurrence to the feed
forward block of terraformer
recurrent layers allow information to
propagate in time
even
even in a single decoder block
okay i think i understood that correctly
so within the feed forward block right
here there is a recurrent connection
between the different tokens
every token goes independently through
that but now we introduce actually a
sort of dependence or a function that
goes from the first token to the second
to the third and so on a recurrent uh
small recurrent neural network and
again they
one can only speculate why they have
this in here i mean they say
that this the results on c4 are minimal
which is their language modeling uh task
and they say the biggest benefits are
when they do like these uh these toy
tasks where you need to copy a decimal
digit and then you can train at on 128
digits but then you can test on
256 so it's over two times longer than
seen in training so they really make
this point that it's for generalization
though it is very very odd like
this is a very odd addition i can i
could get them until like you know here
it says yeah okay you go for long
sequences you know that that's cool long
sequences are cool it's cool if your
model can
you know also do long sequences fine
then
memory efficiency okay you know so given
that this is all sparse and low rank and
so on you also might want uh to use
uh less memory cool
but then
recurrence for this is this is quite an
odd choice i feel and it could be that
it simply
didn't work like
so they also say that the terraformer
here um
in sort of these tasks like
summarization that it sort of beats or
matches state of the art
matches much much larger models and so
on it could i can imagine that their
numbers were
slightly smaller
like slightly worse than kind of the
baselines
and they were just looking for something
to add to pump up those numbers and this
worked if this is the case if that's a
big if
again
it's very dangerous because it might
work for these particular problems and
not for others if not if this was really
just like an idea they had and said well
it'd be cool if that's in there
then you know
good like
i'm willing to i'm willing to accept
that as well
all right so that was the terra former
and here you see so
the terraformer now
has over a 37
x speed up on it's a considerably large
model but for this large model
it requires less than 100 milliseconds
per token
of decoding time
while not degrading in performance too
much
so that is
that is i think quite an achievement
even if it's only for particular types
of tasks like these here it is quite an
achievement and um it's a bit of a shame
that the speed ups are only for like
they're only so huge for the really huge
models i guess it makes sense uh because
these effects are often compounding
uh
you know so it
for you and me with like
uh our regular old computers laptops it
maybe won't make that much a difference
uh in terms of speed it might make a
difference in terms of memory because of
the reversibility
but other than that yeah but it's it's
good for
like
if you work if you want to work with
larger models but you don't necessarily
have to compute and
you do inference
this might be something for you they
specifically say that
not everything has been tried yet they
still don't do quantization which could
yet deliver another speed up and there's
also lots of things to do to sexually
speed up training um maybe there's a way
to get around this gumball soft max need
to forward propagate
uh the true soft max from time to time
and so on
so lots of engineering lots of kind of
choices that are interleaved very hard
to say where gain comes from
but undeniable gain has been made in
huge form
and that's cool alright tell me what you
think i'll see you next time bye